You hear this often:...
...check with your doctor before you start a new exercise program.
A new study shows the wisdom of that advice.
Each year, millions of people find themselves in the emergency room after a heart attack,...
...because they overdid it during an exercise routine or a bout of lovemaking.
Regular cardiovascular exercise reduces the risk of heart problems.
But for the couch potatoes of the world,...
...suddenly launching into a cardio program, or having sex can lead to a heart attack.
Doctors at Tufts University Medical Center in Boston studied the problem...
...and found a direct link between exercise and heart attack for these patients.
Doctors Jessica Paulus and Issa Dahabreh reviewed 14 studies of the exercise - heart attack connection...
...mostly involving men between the ages of 55 and 64.
For those individuals who are unaccustomed to regular physical activity or who did not typically exercise,...
...this risk was much higher than for those individuals who were regular exercisers.
The study showed the greatest risk is during the activity and for up to two hours afterwards.
But should anyone interpret this as an excuse not to exercise,...
...Dr. Paulus says they should think again.
If they are unaccustomed to exercising but they'd like to start becoming more physically active,...
...they should do so very gradually and under the care and supervision of a physician.
Dr. Dahabreh points out that regular exercise is good even for people who have a high risk for heart attack...
...because it conditions the heart to beat more slowly during a strenuous workout or sexual activity.
People who would exercise frequently, regularly, several times per week...
...will tend to have a much smaller increase while they are involved in these specific activities.
The study appears in the Journal of the American Medical Association.
Carol Pearson, VOA News.